when you are hiding something you are
always scared the reason I referenced
the last seed of eight mile all the time
is because it's one of the most
significant popular culture moments
where Eminem as a global Superstar and
Eight Mile as a highly consumed movie
showed you the secret he wins the battle
because he exposes all of his perceived
shortcomings
he's in the trailer with my mom thus
rendering Papa Doc aka the world nothing
to say and so if you're accountable and
say I [__] this up [__] I press the
button you're not scared anymore
if you are able to eliminate the fear of
other people's opinions you will be in a
better position to be accountable
because when you admit you were wrong or
that you were the problem this boogie
monster of everybody laughing at you or
judging you goes away and you can start
leading to accountability